fears that maybe 170 people are still
missing and that
that has been confirmed by the
authorities here we are at the papua 1
dam which is a 530 megawatt dam from
where
uh where the waters and the debris
everything rode
through that those mountains the river
and it crashed through this dam and you
can see the devastation that it caused
now there's a tunnel just below me which
has been
full of debris which is about a mile
long which comes out to the other end
and where the rescue operations are
taking place at the moment they believe
about
38 people may be still
uh alive there there's they've been uh
trying to dig out the mud but it's a a
really hard task for
all the rescuers because this it's been
difficult for them they've only just
managed to get to about 100 meters yet
there's still
it's a mile long and also goes further
about
90 meters further into in
into underground and there are different
sort of tunnels four tunnels
uh where these people have been trapped
there they have
they've got dog squads they've got
choppers flying around
but there has been criticism from some
of the victims
some of the family members who we met
whose family members are working and are
trapped inside they're saying nothing
so far is uh is very positive they all
seem to be quite down and low and and
are
and and they have they have criticized
the whole operation
though we do we have seen for ourselves
there's
there's a multiple agencies working
out here at the same time trying to
rescue and trying to take out the debris
but
just the just the vastness of the debris
that has gone across
this place one can just imagine the kind
of
uh work that has to be done there is
about 20 20 to 24
feet of debris which is still embedded
in all the
in the riverbed